durante estos dos días de debate en la
asamblea varios países han pedido
reformas al consejo de seguridad de la
ONU yo bailén por ejemplo propuso
ampliarlo y hoy se les quiso un llamado
a retirarle este derecho a Moscú qué tan
factible podría ser esta medida
la reforma de Naciones Unidas es algo
cíclico que siempre fracasa porque para
reformarla se necesita la aprobación de
los cinco países con Beto y siempre
alguno Beta o Beta formalmente o da a
entender que va a vetar por lo tanto es
algo cíclico ya pasó hace 15 años cuando
se hablaba de India de Brasil de Japón
de Alemania Pero hay vetos a nivel de
los cinco y a su vez potencias
regionales que no quieren que entren
otros por ejemplo Brasil aspira Naciones
Unidas pero México cree que le
corresponde eventualmente a él digamos
la India no es bien vista por China o
por Pakistán por lo tanto creo que en
este escenario tan complicado tan
realista y tan tan duro que tenemos la
verdad que estar perdiendo tiempo con
esta con esta imposible cíclico que es
la reforma de Naciones Unidas no tiene
mucho sentido Hablemos del anuncio del
presidente Vladimir Putin como lo
mencionamos miles de personas están
apresurando a salir del país a a pesar
de que se anunció que inicialmente se
movilizarían 300.000 reservistas que tan
posibles que esta medida se amplíe hacia
una movilización total
Bueno ya a partir de de mediados de
febrero cuando empezó La Guerra de
Ucrania ya más alrededor de 300.000
personas de clase media clase media alta
profesionales rusos se fueron del país
digamos no y todo indica que en los
últimos meses y a partir de esta
decisión este flujo de un abc1 de
profesionales de personas que hablan
idiomas que están ligados a temas de
tecnología financieros van a seguir
emigrando Este creo que es una de las
sangrías más duras que que va a tener
Rusia como consecuencia de esta guerra
Putin se quedó a mitad de camino digamos
no se pasó de decir que este era una
operación especial para liberar de nazis
Ucrania y pasó después a la amenaza de
hacer una movilización masiva estilo
Segunda Guerra Mundial o Primera Guerra
Mundial se quedó en el medio declaró una
movilización parcial pero igual la
movilización parcial es un síntoma de
extrema debilidad digamos porque la
clave de esta movilización no son estos
300.000 hombres que obviamente mucho
menos capaces que lo que está muriendo
ahora en Ucrania Porque estos son
profesionales y los 300.000 que vendrían
no que hay que entrenarlos hay que
equiparlos hay que motivarlos entrar una
guerra cuando uno está perdidoso no es
la mejor forma de entrar más si uno no
es profesional sino que la clave del
discurso de Putin fue esta idea de
petrificar el territorio controlado
mediante la anexión que se va a hacer
mediante un referéndum seguramente
no muy transparente y anexar la zona de
dombas a Rusia y con ese argumento decir
que si tocan ese territorio si lo
ofensivo ucraniana toca ese territorio
el territorio Ruso y ahí se podría
activar el uso de armas no
convencionales el centro de declaración
de Putin lo más práctico en el corto
plazo es esto y no la movilización
bien Ahora el descontento contra el
anuncio de Putin se ha visto también en
las calles y solo durante la jornada de
hoy se han arrestado a más de 1.300
personas Qué mensaje envía estas
movilizaciones en Rusia
que te lo agarra popular porque era una
guerra que se veía por televisión que se
pensó que era rápida fácil peleada por
ejército profesional por Mercenario del
grupo Wagner por rusos no rusos blancos
sino habitantes de Rusia de minorías
étnica mongola sus becos si uno ve los
rostros de los combatientes en Ucrania
hay muchos rostros asiáticos digamos no
una movilización general implica empezar
a usar ruso de San Petersburgo de Moscú
de las grandes ciudades de capas medias
capas medias bajas y ahí la guerra se
empieza a hacer más impopular
Especialmente cuando ya se ha filtrado a
la a la opinión pública rusa no pedíate
los noticieros incluyendo algunos
noticiero oficiales donde se notan
peleas ya sobre el fracaso de la
operación Pero a nivel de redes sociales
de los rusos que están en el extranjero
que las cosas no andan bien Por lo tanto
digamos no no creo que va a haber ya un
importante resistencia pasiva en muchos
casos in o un mal clima digamos no
especialmente en las zonas urbanas más
desarrolladas y más occidentales de
Rusia que son la base de poder de Putin
y que Putin durante estos siete meses
trató de no tocar digamos no por eso se
resistió siete meses a llamar esto una
guerra y se resistió siete meses a lo
que todo le pedían desde hace seis meses
o cinco meses que era reforzar la fuerza
terrestre en Ucrania